よろしくお願いします
プッパニヘーワパチナムタングニャーサッダマナサンナラン
スッタングマングマホーゴーマッチュアーダヤガッチャティ
という偈で それに繋げて次の偈もあると思いますけど
別々ですね 釈迦唱では
で プッパニヘーワパチナムタム
皆様テキストをお持ちですから意味はわかると思いますけど
プッパニヘーワパチナムタム
パチナムタムというのは花を集めることで
プッパニっていうのは花のことですね
花集めている ヴィパッサッタマナサンナラン
ヴィパッサッタっていうのは落ち着いてないというね
興奮している マナサンっていうのは心
心が興奮状態にいる人々
人 そんなような感じで
スッタングマングマホーゴー
あるいはもう一つ例え
村人はずっと熟睡している間
夜 マホーゴー 大洪水が来て持っていくような感じでということで
マッチュアーダヤガッチャティ
誰でも死んでしまいますよと
いわゆる知らぬうちに
あっという間に死んでしまいますよということなんです
それは一応仏教の世間の見方であって
賛成する人も反対する人もいるかもしれませんですけど
仏教は大体そういう風に世の中を見ているんですね
で この花を集めるということは
あまり日本の方々にはちょっと理解できないことだと思います
インドでは日常生活にはよく花を使うんです
別にかざりものという意味ではないんです
いろんなところ いろんな行事に
日常生活に花っていうのは必要になる
ですから売り物にもなるし
集めて売ったりもするし
首にかけたりもするし
ベッドに入れたりもするし
あれこれといろんなことで花を使うんです
夏なんかは体中いろいろ
帽子の代わりに首回りにいろんなところに花をつけていると
体の熱がなくなって体が涼しくなる
そういういろいろことがあります
宗教儀式礼にも花を使います
そういうことだから 日常生活にかなり密着しているものなんですね
花っていうのは それで花集めなくちゃいけないんですね
だから普通にしている人々はいろんなところに行って
花が咲いているところに行って
もう一生懸命花を集めるんです
花を集めて バケツなんかにいっぱいつけて
それで街で売ったりする
それでこの貧しい人々はね
大体花を集めるために技術は必要ではありません
だからインドの差別社会で
普通の社会でまとめの仕事をやらせてくれない人々は
そういうカーストの人々は一応花集めたりはする
だから いろんなところに行って
花咲いているところを探して探して行って
必死で集めて集めて もう大量に持ってきて
家から家へ行って それを売るんです
そういう状態だったら
もう花を見るとすごい興奮するんですよ
今日は何かご飯食べられるぞと
で 時々一日中花集めて
一日中花っていうのは朝しか集まりませんから
集めてももしかすると一日の生活費にはならないかもしれませんし
ですから いっぱい花が咲いているのを見ると
どういう気持ちでしょうかと
それ楽しいんですよ だから皆様方は花を見て楽しむこととはずいぶん違うんです
こちらの現代人間の生活には花っていうのは密着しているわけじゃなくて
もうずいぶんもう微妙な関係しかないんです
たまたまどこかに挿しておくだけのことで
それにも膨大なお金がかかってしまうんだから
どちらかというとない方がいいということになるようなもんで
生活に日常生活に密着しちゃうと
そういうふうにはうまくいかないんですね
必ず必要になるんですよ
それでも花っていうのは高いものではありませんし
ですから この そういう貧しい人々がね
何か食べていられるか
もう一日ごとに何か口に入れられるかとかね
それぐらいの貧しい生活をしている人々にとってはね
森に入ったら いっぱい花が咲いているところを見ると大変興奮します
なんて幸せですかと それはもう命に関わっているもので
これでなんとか今日はご飯食べられるということでね
そういうことになっていると
みんなそういう人々はわっと集めて
お互いに喧嘩しながら
もう競争しながら必死に花を集まるんですよ
とにかく何がなんだか分からなくなっちゃうんですね
自分のバケツをいっぱいもう花詰めたいという必死で
もう喧嘩しながら花集めるんですよ
これは私は先に見つけたんだからとかね
あなた出てけとかね お互いに喧嘩したりもすることもあるし
そういう感じで だからこの時は
この次に何が起こるかっていうことはまるっきり気にしない
もしかすると に登ったところでもう花がいっぱいある枝を見つけて
もうあまりにも欲張ってそこをいたところで枝が折れるかもしれませんし
足が滑って落ちるかもしれませんし
怪我するかもしれません
死ぬかもしれないのはもうもうもう考える暇もないんですね
あまりにも興奮しちゃって
それで一つの枝の花を取っている間でも周りを見ているんですね
周りの他の枝やらね 他の隣の木やらね
もっと前の前の木木木やらね
そういうものを見て あちらも花がいっぱい
これよりはあの木の方がいいんじゃないかとかね
もうちょっと先へ行った方がいいんじゃないかとか
必死になっちゃうんですね
だからすごい興奮状態で花を摘むことになるんですね
だからプッパーニヒュパチナンタンペアサッタマナサンナラン
そういう人々の状況をイメージして欲しがるんですね
それは皆様に無理だと思いますけどね
どんな気持ちでしょうかということは
で 番目の例えば この すごく気持ちよくもう寝ている
で 突然 洪水が来て村をそのまま流してしまうということで
その時でも人々は全然周りの環境には気づかない
ただグーグーと寝ているだけで
で 突然水が流れてきちゃうと
それもインドにはあり得る話で
インドはちょっと大きい国ですから
ある地方ではまるっきりもうもうもう乾季で水一滴もない
もう川はもうこれが川ですかと思うほどのもう枯れてるかもしれませんだけど
ヒマラヤの方に雨が降ったところで
突然水がもう何メートルも
高い水がサッと出てくる時はあるんですね
だからこれは推測も何もできません
雨が降って降って降って
もしかすると洪水になるかもしれませんで
そういう順番で出てくるものでもないんです
ほとんど雨が降らないところであろうとも
突然川がもう大量の水が流れてきて
そこら辺全部もう洗い流しちゃうということもあり得るんですね
だから予測はできない
当時は 今もインドのこの橋とか見るとものすごい長いんですよ
なんで村の上まで橋を作っているのかと
川の橋なんですけど 水が来る時はそこら辺全部もう浸水するんです
それもほとんど一年一回ぐらいのことなんですけど
やっぱりそれでも橋が流れてしまっちゃうとね
まあどうにもならんだから
橋はちゃんとそこら辺計算して
今作っている橋なんかはもう一年一回でも来るだろうと推測する
水の量を計算して作っているんです
でも人々はそこら辺に村を作って住んでいるんですよ
だからいつ流されてしまうかとわからないんですね
それも経験できないんだからね
そんなわからないというかもしれませんだけどね
まあ知らんぷりをしてるんですけど
そういうことは日本でもよく起こることで
突然ね 雪崩が起きたり
地すべり 地すべりが起きたりして
夜真夜中に寝ている人々はそのままカシャーンといっちゃうということは一応あります
だいたい地震にしたっても
まあ決まっていて 冬と夜起こるんだからね
だからまあ なんでそういうことになってるかっていうことは
私に聞いても知りませんだけど
一応もう冬で一番最悪な状態で
また夜ということで大地震が起きたりすると
で どうにもならない これは昼間に起きても
突然起きたらそれはどうにもならない
昼間大地震が起きたって
みんなもう外に出て活動しているところだからね
その時も潰れるときは潰れてしまいます
[音楽]そういうことで
我々は期待しないうちに
予測もしていないうちに
突然死んでしまうんですね
人間というのは それで世間の人々は
まあそういうことはもう別にもうなかったことにしましょうと
ないことにしましょうと
とことん元気で できるだけ金儲けて生きていればありがたいではないかということにするんです
仏教の世界ではもうそんなことではなくて
もう事実はいつどんな瞬間で人が死ぬかもしれませんし
死ぬということはわからないし
確実に起こるし ですから
何よりも先にそれ考えておきなさいと
我々はいつでも死ぬかもしれません
これは突然起こりますよと
因果法則から見れば 物事は突然ということは成り立ちませんだけど
例えば突然花が咲いたりはしませんし
突然実ったりはしませんしね
突然雨が降ったりもしませんしね
だから一応じわじわと原因が揃ってくるんだから予測できますよ
死はどうする？死はそうじゃないんですよ
突然起こるんですね だから死に因果法則は関係ないという話ではないんです
それも因果法則ですけど
やっぱりじわじわと原因が揃ってきて
ああ やっと結果ということにはないんですね
だから年取って病気になって
寝たきりになって どんどん内臓の機能が衰えていて
食べ物も取れなくなっていったとか
そういうふうにゆっくり枯れて死ぬ場合は
いくらか予測はできますけどね
世の中の死っていうのは
それよりはかなり突然死の方が数が多いんです
だから事実を無視するか認めるかということで
だから世間ではそんな暗い話はやめなさいと
そんなことを考えちゃうと
もう楽しく生きていられないんだということで
儲かることはできなくなるんだと
というふうに思うんですね
で 人間は幸福ですごい楽しく穏やかにできているんだったら
それではいいんだけど
そういう人々に限って
金儲かること とにかく食って食べて寝て
そこだけにすべて精神力・エネルギーを使っている人々に限って
もうもう大変なんですね
自分でも幸せで生きていないし
周りにも幸せでい 生かしてあげないんですね
とにかく競争やら争いやら
もう殺しやら嫉妬やら憎しみやら
もうありとあらゆる問題作って
人間の幸福をもう無茶苦茶粉々に壊してるんですよ
この何主義者でしたっけ？このもう
楽観主義者たちが で この間も話になったんですけど
まあこのまあ例えば会社にしたら
まあまあ上司がとことんもう部下から仕事をさせてほしがったりとかね
部下はなんかあまりにも仕事ありすぎて
もう辞めたいとかね まあ断りたいんだけど断れないとかね
この間聞いたのはこのうまい断り方法はあるんでしょうか？という質問でしたけどね
そういう風な場合でも
この会社であろうが何であろうが
すごい楽しく穏やかで気持ちよく
お互いにすごい楽しく機嫌よくニコニコと仕事できるはずなんです
でもこの素晴らしい 何て言いますか
このオプティミス 楽観主義
の人々はいつでも顔がきついわ
人は侮辱するわ 人を貶すわ
ちょっとしたことで怒るわ
どこで楽観主義かとわからないんですよ
人間いつ死ぬかわかりませんよ
なんてつまらない話持ってくるんでしょうかと怒るだけで
それに怒るんですね なんで無駄な話を持ってくるんですか？と
あんたは暗いんだと 実際
この楽観主義者たちほど暗い人間っていうのはいないんです
だから 例えば会社でいい仕事をしていければ
みんな楽しく穏やかで
お互いの気持ちをね いつでも楽しく穏やかにしながら仕事をすれば
うまくいくでしょうし
例えば上司がね これこれやりたまえというんじゃなくて
これちょっとお願いしますとかね
これぐらいこれ今日中やってくれれば本当に助かりますよと
そういう風にほんの微妙に言葉を変えるだけで仕事は楽になるんですよ
ちょっと仕事は溜まってますけど
ちょっとこれやってくれれば本当に大変助かりますよと言うと
もう帰ろうとしている部下から
はい わかります ではやりますということになるんです
そうすると 自分の気持ちで自分の意思でやるんだから
決して嫌な仕事になりません
今日は早く帰るんじゃないと仕事溜まってるんだから
と言っちゃうと 同じ仕事なのにものすごくストレス溜まるわ
苦しくなるわ やる気にはならないし
なんでこの上司へてめえ死んでやるという風にも思ったりもするし
早く死んでくれないかとかね
私にも聞こえたんですから
私でもあんた早く死んでくれないかっていうことはね
私はそれはちょっとどうかわからない
あんたに言われることじゃないんだと
で さらに問題が悪化するだけで
で だからそういうことを言うと
もう本当はもう私はすごくニコニコと楽しく説法することができますけどね
これはできないようにしたんですよ
だから私は全然気にしない
自分が蒔いた種を自分で刈りなさいと
わざとわざと楽しく冗談言いながら
みんな穏やかな気分にしながら言わんと
だからやっぱりまあちょっとしたことで我々は問題を全部もう壊してしまうんですよ
なんでそうするんですかというと
もう命は永遠なりやと
私は決して死ぬはずがないんだと
だから儲かりたい放題儲かるんだと
支配したい放題支配するんだと
そういう生き方なんですね
そこで人間としてはものすごく我々は品格がもう徹底的に落ちてしまうんですね
だって食い物にしか能がないことになってるんですね
小さい時からも子供に何を教え
道徳を教えることはゼロ
いい人間になりなさいというところも
もうもうもう口を潰しても言わない
とにかくいい成績出しなさいと
そればっかり知ってるんです
何のためにいい成績でしょうかと
頭が悪くてもいいんです
物事を考える能力なくてもいいんです
だからもう３０秒単位で塾に行かすんですね
そうすると同じことを１万回も繰り返すんだから
犬にもできますからね
それぐらい繰り返しちゃうと
それで点数は取れるんですけど
点数 あの同じことばっかり繰り返すことによって
人間本来持っている あの
なんています イマジネーションやら新しい考え方を出してくる能力やらインスピレーションやら
脳のそういう働きは全部死んでしまうんです
だから結局お話になったらマニュアルでないと動かないんですね
で こういう電話でいろいろ人を誘惑して物を売る場合でも
向こうは暗記した文章をザーっともう言ってるだけで
これで電話を受ける側もみんなワンパターンで
もうレミータジェみたいな生き方をしているんだから
もう決まってる反応しかしないんですね
だから３０分の電話会話は成り立つんですよ
私は２回 ３回ぐらい私にも電話があって
私はすぐこういうことを言ったら
必ずこういう返事日本人ならするだろうと知っています
するでしょうと 全く想像できない突飛な返事をするんです
それでも１分も経たないで電話切りませんだけど
会話がカチンと向こうで止まるんですよ
[笑い] 次にどう言えばいいかわからなくなっちゃって
[笑い] 私はもうざまあみろということで待ってるんですね
だから向こうはプロでしょうと
それで私が「あなたは何のために電話したんですか？」と 「
思い出してあげる 何か目的あったでしょう」と 「
自分が電話した目的を言ったらどうですか？」と
それでもう大恥なんですよ
だから結局はそういう社会っていうのは危ないんですよ
もうマンネリできてるね
あのインスピレーションない人間っていうのはもうすごく危ないんです
インスピレーションがなくても生きていられるというのは動物だけなんですよ
だからなんでそうなっているのかというと
子供の時からも この人間として立派に品格よく生きるということはね
人間らしく それは教えてない
それはもう禁止 憲法違反
そんなことを教えると
人を殺すことだけ勉強しなさいと
で それでうまくいってるかというと
うまくいってないんですよ
あらゆる不正が起こる
あらゆる犯罪が起こる
で 小学生まで人殺しにまでいく
それは自然法則に逆らっていることですよ
小学生の年の人っていうのは人殺しっていうことはね
自然法則にまで人間 生命としてのね
ライオンの子供でも一人前になってから狩りに行くんだからね
子供の時は狩りに行かない
そこら辺にうろうろうろうしているだけで
で 親が獲物を取ったら
もうそちらにぱあっと飛んでいって
餌を食べるんであって
チーターももう狩りに行っちゃうと
もういつでもチーターの場合はもう子供はもうずーっとぴったりついてますよ
で 狩りに行くと なんか喉からちょっと音を出すんですね
音を出した途端 子供たちはサッと草の中でギシッとしゃがんで動かない
また母親戻るまで 全くも動かない
ちょっとでも動いちゃったら誰かに殺されますからね
で 餌を取って また親が声出しちゃうと
もう立ち上がって飛んでいって
また動く だからだいたい小さい時は
まあそういう攻撃するとかね
というのはありえないんですけどね
だからそうやって自然まで壊れている
だからこの楽観主義で
もう何を着ればかっこいいかとか
どんなお化粧すればよろしいかとかね
どんな薬塗った方がもうもうもう落ちてる毛が生えてくるかとかね
で 何を食っちゃえば痩せるのかとかね
もう食べれば太るんですけど
で 何を食べれば痩せるんでしょうかとかね
まあそういうことしか頭にないんですよ
それって立派な人間かと
で それでもうどうなるのかというと
我々はとにかく儲けなくちゃいけないし
高価な服を買わなくちゃいけないし
高価な家を作らなくちゃいけないしとかね
隣の人には絶対負けてはいけませんし
という価値観で生きてるんですよ
だから残るのは心に憎しみやら嫉妬やら落ち込みやら恨みやら
暗いというと もうあまりにも暗い
やがて道路に出て歩くことさえもできなくなっちゃうんですね
まあ怖いと 子供たちにも自由にそこら辺で公園でむちゃくちゃ遊ぶことはもうできない
遊ぶ連中ないんだから
もう だからそういう恐ろしい世界を作って全然認めないんですよ
だから全然子供なんか見えますかね
瞬時に見えますよ 学校から帰ってくる
ちょっとほんの瞬間 それからまたいない
また戦っています 塾で
だから不自然な生き方だから不自然な行動はする
だから完全なもう暗い社会を作って
我々こそすごい楽観主義で楽しく生きてるんだぞと言って自分に言い返してるんですね
だからその問題っていうのは
このある日突然この社会で起きたものではなくて
この人類っていうのはもう死なないぞ
死なないぞというすごい誤解で生きてるんですね
だから死なないぞ 死なないぞというすごい誤解でいると
どんな社会でもそういう運命になるんです
で こちらのモデルになっているアメリカ社会は明るいんですかと
そんな明るいとひとかけらもないんですよ
そうと言っていると危ない
危ない ビクビクしていないと
これはフリーウェイに乗ったんだからといってフリーはないんですよ
もういつ何が起こるかわからない
遠いところに行っても
ガソリン入れようとしても
ガソリンスタンドはちゃんともう100キロために100かな
じゃないんだけど 一応ありますけど
ちょこちょこちょこちょこところでも30分 30
分ぐらいあることはあるんだけど
もう人はいない いる人は中でも厳重にもう鉄板でドア閉めてかけて鍵をかけて
小さな窓だけあって そこの中に隠れているんですよ
だからそこでカードを出したり
何とかしたら まあ7番目ですよというだけで
自分が7番目のあれ 何て言いますか
ポンプを入れて もうガソリン自分で入れるんだから
アメリカではね それ終わったらもうカード返してサッと車に乗って逃げるしかないんです
だから欲だけの世界っていうのはもう人間見ると震える世界なんですよ
楽観主義の最終的なところは
それでも認めないっていうね
だから仏教では事実をありのままに見てくださいと
そんなに執着するなよと
楽に生きなさいと 必死で金を儲けたっても明日死ぬかもしれませんよと
だから命はいつ終わるものかとわからない
もうこれは定めてないんだと
いつでも死ぬことだけは
いつでも簡単に起こるものであると思うと
初めて自分をやっぱり 1日でも守ってやるぞという気持ちにはなるし
人に攻撃する気持ちも出てこないし
短い命だから攻撃したり喧嘩したりする暇がないんだから楽しくしましょうと
で 私は原始社会で育てられたんだから
で 時々耳に入るんですね
いろいろ財産の争いありましたとかね
兄弟で親の土地に喧嘩するとかね
時々１本の木にもすごい喧嘩する時あります
親が兄弟に土地を分けると
同じ土地だからやっぱり隣同士になっちゃうし
そこで上の人 この木私が必要やと
弟 いえ 私に必要やと で
なかなか線を引けなくなっちゃうな
線の上に木があるんだからね
大変ですよ すごい喧嘩になる
簡単なのは木をもう切って捨てちゃえばいいんですけど
やっぱりそれはどちらでもやりたくないんですね
まあかなりもうよっぽど用がない限りは木を切らない
向こうの連中 人々は 最近違いますけどね
最近はもうもう見たらもう鬼みたいに切ってしまうんですね
だからもう年中雨が降る国ですけど
今見てみると砂漠みたいな状態で
山なんかはハゲ 全部ハゲ
山ばっかしで全部木を切っちゃって
それは最近の楽観主義が導入してからの結果なんです
で 私が生まれた地方っていうのは
もうもう我々は英語でこのウェットゾーンと言うんですよ
もう沼とかいっぱいあるあったんですよ
で 畑でももう危ないんですよ
もう泥がもうどこまであるかわからないんです
もう頭の上まで それでも田んぼは作ったりはするし
そういう人々知ってます
もうどうやってやれば
それ楽なんですよ 土が硬くないんだから
ただ上に生えてる草だけ取って種まけばいいんです
こういうもう豊作になります
今はない ほとんどもう毎日というか
二日一回ぐらいは雨降ってたんですけど
もう土はもう石のように硬い
今は木はないんですよ
猿もいたんですけども
すごい街なんですけどね
街なんですけど もう野生の猿もいて
もう遊んでいるわ もう我々も猿の間から学校に行ってしましたし
何のこともないんです
時々私たちは猿の方が追っかけて行ったりもするし
猿たちが逃げたりするし
一緒にいたんですよ 特にちっちゃな子供の猿とか見ると
もうどうしても捕まりたくなっちゃうんですね
こいつは足が弱いんだから
もしかすると捕まえるぞとかね
って思っていくと やっぱり猿たちは母親がもうすぐ子供を取って逃げちゃうし
攻撃はしないんですね
人間には もういません
だからそれがこの楽観主義でも
とにかく金やと 何よりも大事なのは金やということになったら
もう自然そのものが破壊してしまうんです
その破壊はまたもう百年
二年でも元には戻らないんですよね
千年経っても 一旦破壊しちゃったら
日本でいう伊勢エビというロブスターなんか食べないんですよ
そんくらいもうゴロゴロゴロゴロいたんだから
川に入ってもう水浴びでもしようったら
もういてあっち行けという感じ
追い出しても 子供の頃
時々漁師やらね 動物殺したりする人々は捕まってまあ撃ったりはするんですけど
あまりにも美しくて このロブスターがね
なんか宝石みたいな背中が青い
輝いてるんですね 背中が
もうあの あれ長い  触覚ですか
触覚ありますね なんて美しいかと
もう信じられないほど綺麗なでしたけど
種類は違うかどうかわかりませんだけどね
私は見て感動するね なんて綺麗な生き物かなと
で 今ない それで言いたかったのは
この 昔はね 昨日一本の木のためにも喧嘩ぎゅうぎゅうと喧嘩すると
周りの大人たちが何言うのかと
お前ら死なないつもりですか？と
持っていくんですよ それはと
よく聞く言葉なんですよ
持っていくつもりですか？と
持っていくつもりっていうのは
死ぬ時はお前持っていくのかっていうことをすごい短くしています
だから死も死を考えるのは当たり前で
そこまで言わなくてもみんなすぐ分かりますよ
それ持っていくのかと
そうすると いくらかでも教育ある人だったら
すごく恥ずかしくなるんですよ
喧嘩やめちゃうんです
問題が解決したわけじゃない
それでも私が欲しいっていうことあるんだけど
喧嘩はやめちゃうんですね
で 村の大人たちが喧嘩させない場合は
もう問題は決めてはないんだけど
昨日はお互いこちらの方がこちら取ったり
こちらがこちら取ったりとかはします
だからまあ人が財産にいろんなことに欲が出てしまって
ものすごい喧嘩になった時でも
この死の概念がすぐ中和してくれるんですよ
いきなり また人間に戻してくれるんですよ
持っていくんでしょうかと聞いたところで
誰でも死ぬんだよと そうすると喧嘩する意味がないんだと
だから生きている場合は持っていけるものを収集しなさいと
持っていけないものは
いくら溜まっても溜まっても意味がないんだと
それで人間が死ぬ時は持っていけるものは何なのかというと
道徳しかないんですよ
自分の良い行いしかないんですよ
自分の心しかないです
だから美しい穏やかな心を作るんですよ
優しい心を作るんですよ
善行をするんですよ 物を奪うんじゃなくて
人にものをあげようとするんですよ
あげて人を助けたと言ったら
その心に残る その穏やかさがね
ずっと心に残りますからね
私はこういういいことをしましたと
そういうことで 人間が置いておくものではなくて
持っていけるものに興味を持って
そこを育てようとする
そうすると すごい人格のある人間が自然に現れてきます
だから ブッダの考え方は
やっぱり人がいつでも瞬時に死んでしまうんだよと
これまだ突然だよと それを認めて頭の念頭に入れておくと
それで本当に平和な社会は築けるんですよ
一人一人穏やかに生きていられるんです
それがない限り なかなか大変難しいんですよ
笑いなさいと言っても笑いなさいと言って笑っちゃうと逃げたくなるんですよ
笑顔じゃないんですそれが
だから笑うことも今は塾があるでしょうに
どうすれば笑えるのかとかね
いわゆる訓練させるんですよ
この人相手に商売する場合は
一応そういう会社とかのところで
こういう風に笑いなさいとか
お辞儀はこういう風にしなさいとかね
もう完全にロボットになってますよ
あの作り笑いほどもう私は気持ち悪いんですけどね
で すごいいたすら好きだからね
もし機会があったら何かいじめてはやります
その作り笑いにはちょっとしたことで消しちゃうんです
決してこちらはものすごく明るく笑うんです
だからこの そういう風にも
この我々はいつでも死んでしまうんだと
命は儚いものであると
自分の己の命は儚いものであると
よくよく分かると 本物のポジティブ思考になるんです
それがお釈迦様も思うポジティブ思考なんですよ
いわゆる実効主義で生きているということなんです
いつでも死んでしまうんだから
じっとしていられないでしょうに
[笑い]怠けたり 嫉妬したり
落ち込んだり そんな時間無駄にする暇がないでしょうに
ほんの短い命だから 充実して生きていなきゃ損でしょうに
だから 本格的なポジティブ
肯定的な思考を作りたければ
事実を認めるしかない
事実に背いたったらね
どんな嘘を言っても もうものすごい結果として
もう暗黒になってしまいます
だから私たちはそういう立場でいるんです
仏教は決して悲観主義でもないし
暗い教えでもない たった人類の唯一の明かりはそれこれだけやと
しかし 外から仏教を見てみると
何やこれと思うかもしれません
それはそちらの考え方で
森いっぱい花が咲いて
人間が明るく話すやってる
僕はすごいこと楽しいんじゃないかと
で 仏教ではそうやってバカなことをやってるんですけど
お前らはと いつ死ぬかわからないんだと
木から 枝から落ちて死んじゃいますよと
だから興奮状態でいるんじゃないんだと
だから寝ている村が水に流されるということは
準備していないという意味なんですよ
あの労働して なんとか 1日の収入でなんとか命繋げている貧しい人々が森いっぱい花が咲いていると
もう大興奮する なんて綺麗な花ですかという
このもう無意味な興奮じゃ楽しみじゃないんです
だから桜の花が咲いたら
あの興奮というのはすっごい品のない
と言っても 別にこちら食い物あるんだから問題ないんですけど
あの まずそれで生活させてる人々の楽しみっていうのは
それ何か違うでしょうに
それは本格的な興奮ですよ
これでやっと子供にもうご飯ちょっと食べさせるんだよという気持ちはね
涙糸の感動 喜びじゃないんですよ
自分の子供は昨日も何も食べてなかったと
夜も泣きながらお腹空いたままで寝たんだと
朝ちょっと森に行ったら花がいっぱい咲いていると
これその感動と皆様桜の花を見て
それは随分もう桁違いますよ
だから まあ皆様にはそういう風な感動
やっぱりそうしたね 私はその生き方は幸せだと思いますよ
なぜか すっごい感動するんだからね
これでうちの子供になんとか今日はちょっとお腹いっぱい食べさせるんだよと
その喜びは生きる喜びなんですよ
それはもうとっくにないでしょう
今人を喜ばせるっていうことは全く無理
ありえない どんなお土産持って来たってありえないでしょう
私にしたら同じことです
くれるなよと 迷惑やと
置く場所がないんだからね
で スリランカ人の法事があって行かなくちゃいけないんだけど
思い出すたびに気持ち悪くなるんですよ
これを 4年前 何かもうくれちゃって
お土産で いまだにあるんで
箱ままそのままで その前もらったものはこちらで処分したんですね
ガスコンロ なんかこちらたくさんにして
この機会で これはとにかく処分して楽にならなくちゃとこちらに持ってきたんですけど
またありまして ガスコンロじゃないし
もう役に立たないし これどうしようかと
もう今度は行って 何かこれ避ける方法ないのかと頭の中で考えているんですね
避けられないんですね
お坊さん呼んだらもう何かもうお布施という感じで何かしなものくれるんだから
これ だから現代社会ではそういうことで
人がせっかくお金払って買ってる品物でも
もらう側にとっては迷惑やと
だからなんかね 豊かな人ってどうなったんでしょうかと
生きる喜びが消えちゃったんですよ
だからね 誰でも寿命は決まってるし
現代の人々もね そのまま年を取って死ぬでしょうに
まあやがてものすごい感動する
興奮することが起きるだろうと思って
起きないでしょうに そのまんまつまらないままで死んじゃうと思いますけど
だからすごい無理をするんですよ
現代人は楽しむために
で こちらちょっと前にNHKで BST なんか日本の歌というド派手な番組がありまして
で NHK だからね 出演者に金払わないんだからね
もう誰でも大物は呼ぶ呼ぶ
で 技術は最高だから 音はすごい立派で
だからまあじゃあ聞いてやるかと
で 技術はいいし もう撮影もね
そういう能力はもう全部もう 1流だからね
まあそこはすごい それはまあてきぱきと見ていて
まあこれはもう日本のね
もうすごい大物の人々も歌ってるんですけど
すっごくもう気持ち悪くなったんですね
みんな同じテーマですね
何歌っても 船が出ていくはもう波止場でしたっけ
そこであなたには二度と会えないと知ってるんですけど
未練が残る それだけなんですね
これであれこれと工夫して歌うと気持ち悪い
歌えないのかと それでも最近また都はるみで都はるみが出た
あ またかと思ったんですけど
曲は聞いたことはなかったんですね
それ喜んだんですよ 昔というタイトルで
で 昔々何でもうまくいったようなという歌なの
それあ これがいいやと
だから昔々はもう何でもうまくいったような
俺 本当の話ですよと で
なんだかんだもうまくいっていたんだよと
それでどんどん歌の中に入ってくると
昔っていうのはお化けなんですね
だからこれはもう昔は昔は昔は昔華でしたと
昔っていうのはそのお化けが昔は華でしたと
で 昔は昔は昔もうかっこよかったと
で そこはすごい速いビートで
もうものすごい速いビートで
かなり明るく ただそれだけいい歌やと思ったんですけど
他はなんかお腹が痛くなるほど気持ち悪くなるんで
だからといってそちら才能ないわけでもそんなことじゃないんですよね
ものすごい抜群の歌唱力で
ものすごい丁寧に ものすごく立派に歌うんですよ
でも楽しくないんです
私にはね これ個人的な主観で
なんてつまらないかと
なんてアイデア貧か 貧
何と言いますか え？ 貧困
貧困でしょうかと なんでこの人々に人生の喜びを謳えないかと
喜んだ経験ないんだからね
そこで言葉は私にもわかる言葉で
昔っていう歌は全部言葉はすごい単純で
もうなんか子供に物語を言うような調子で
ビートはすごい速い ものすごいもう演歌としてはありえない
もうロックみたいんですよ
で あれを聴いて あ いい歌よ
これは楽しい歌やと それ終わったらまた北の宿を始めたんだから
本当に私にはものすごく暗く
ものすごく暗く感じるんですね
まあいいやという とにかく私たちはこの豊かなって
なんかどうでしょうかと
なんか失ったんですよ
生きる喜びっていうものを
だからブッダの時代では
まあ一部の人間はすごい豊かだったんですけど
そういう人々はほとんど出家しちゃったんですよ
つまらないと お釈迦様は一人でしょうし
もう桁違いの豊かさでいて
結局すべて捨てて出家しちゃったんです
そこでやっと幸福っていうのが見つかるんですよ
何もないことの幸福 で
お釈迦様は日常会う人々はみんなものすごい大変
やっと生きてる人々だから
そういう例えの中でも
やっぱりイメージとしてお釈迦様も知っていたでしょうね
どれほどこの貧しい やっと生計立てている
やっと食べている人々は
花が見るともう興奮状態で
人の話なんか耳に入りません
もうあっち行けという感じで
もう必死になって鬼に乗って花に飛びかかるでしょう
もう集め集め集めようと
そこで互いに喧嘩する
このフィリピンとかいろんな貧しい国々のところ
テレビで皆様かっこつけてテレビ見ないんだからね
そういう情報番組見てください
もう正しいものは報道しませんだけど
でもいくらか報道  1つの報道番組の1万分の1ぐらいは事実はあるんです
そういうところでゴミ箱で喧嘩する子供たちいるでしょうね
フィリピンで ゴミ捨て場で
箱じゃないんです 何を入れてるかというとビニール袋なんですよ
ものすごい臭いハエがいって
もうゴミを捨てるんですね
そちらに行ってビニールを集め集めて
それはもう洗うかどうか分かりませんだけど
それなんかどこかで売って
もう 1週間頑張っても円
円の収入はないんでしょうにね
そちらでもそれでも喧嘩するんですよ
だからそれはものすごい見ていられないほど悲しい出来事ですけど
でもかえってそうやってなんとかもうやっと 10円でも儲かったら
それで家に帰って 家っていう家じゃないんですけどね
もうなんとかハットみたいなものに帰って
みんなでパンとかなんとか買ってきて食べる時のあの喜びの顔っていうのに
だから貧しいのはいいってわけじゃないんですよし
だからって豊かさってわけではないと思いますよ
どちらでも同じくなっちゃいますからね
貧しい人々はもう悲しくて苦しくてたまらない生き方をして
そこで怒り憎しみが出てくる
ビニール袋も捨てたゴミでしょうに
これ俺のものやと言って
子供たちがお互いにやっちゃうんだと
豊かになるとまた同じ現象が現れるんですよ
同じでつまらないことに憎しむんですよ
つまらないことに離婚もする
また怒り憎しみで またもうもうどちらでも同じ場所に
なっちゃいますよ そこが理解してほしいんですよ
貧困に陥っちゃうと そちらにあるのは憎しみ
苦しみ 嫉妬 盗み 殺し 豊かになったらあるのは何でしょうか
憎しみ 嫉妬 殺し合い 誘拐
毎日怯え だからそういう愚かな生き方
生徒がするのかと だからお釈迦様はどちらの極端にも関係なく
すごい立派な生き方 理性におとづけなさい
事実を見なさい 人は誰でも死ぬんだよ
長生きできるわけじゃないんだよと
だから互いに労わりあって仲良くしようと
たった一日でも有効に事実感を持って生きてみなさいよと
だから死ぬ準備という言葉になるんです
これがもう必然的なもので
絶対やらなくちゃいかんことで
必ず死ぬんだから だから私には原始時代
原始社会で育てられたんだから
もう最初の頃でどんどん頭に叩き込んだのはこの嫉妬という概念なんです
母親が教えたのは いつでも目の前にそれがあるんだよと
威張るんじゃないよと
それで脅されて もう男も三人もいたんだからね
もう並べて かなりもう母にしてはね
手に負えないでしょうし
結構手に負えないんですよ
私にだってわかるでしょう
人の話を聞かないんだから
もう 頭下げるを知らないんです
でも微妙にでも間違いしない人間として
もうきちんと育てたんだからね
だからそれはもうすごい道具になったのはブッダの教えなんですね
だから考えてみれば もう私
本当にもう我強いというか
もう頭下げませんよ だから今も兄弟ではかなりお互いに結構火をつける
誰も負けたくはないんです
だからもうほとんど喋れないんですよ
というわけで 仲が悪いわけはまっとうきりないんです
何か問題あったらそれはちゃんとやってあげますけど
例えば弟の何か問題あったらやってあげますけど
いない時やってあげて
また出ていくんです 私は助けてあげて
向こうはもう認めたくないんだからね
あんたに助けてたまるかって
で 同じことで私に何かあったらもう
何とか言うんだ 言うんですか
言ったらやってくれますけど
やっぱりまた同じ調子で
そういう連中をね もう問題を起こさないように育てるっていうことは
もう女性の場合は大変やと思いますけど
でもブッダの教えがありましたから
もうぎっしりと ですから
この死を知るということは
決して暗いエネルギーのない人間になるわけじゃないんです
死を認めることで すごい気楽になるんです
気楽になると頭が回転しますよ
もし皆様の頭の中でも
まだ根っこ一つだけでも残っていたならば
インスピレーションとかね
そういう方で 脳細胞のまだもしかすると芽が出てくるかもしれません
根こそぎに取ったならば
もうそれも知らない そこら辺の脳は全部もう死してるんだったら知りませんだけど
だから大事なのは何なのかと
事実を目の前にして何が大事かということは考えなくちゃいけないんですね
仏教ではこれ まあこれ英語ではUrgencyという言葉を使いますけど
この必然性ですね おそらく
緊急性というかね 緊急状態だと
どんな人間でも火事がある場合は馬鹿力が出ると言っているような感じで
このじっとしていられないなる状態に置かれたら
かなりエネルギーが出てくるんですよ
のんびりできんと だから
それは本当に理性に基づいて
もう人は誰でも死ぬということで
今日も死ぬかもしれませんということで
私は別にすごい調子節を入れて
一人で楽しく もう毎朝やってるし
夜も遅いんだからね 本もいろいろ本も読みたいしね
もうだからやらないんですけど
一応もう寝る前にも 人間の命っていうのは本当につまらなくて
もう惨めやという経典を流して聞いているんです
それを聞いて寝るんです
楽しいんですよ 人の命っていうのはもう印もなし
もう何も知らぬうちにすぐもう死んでしまう
ものすごい惨めやと 死んでいく人を助けるということは
物っきりありえないんだと
木の上にある熟した実がね
すぐ落ちるんだからね
そんな命や それ聞いて寝るんですよ
別に暗いわけじゃないんです
明るくなるんですよ 全部忘れられます
だから この 死に対する考え方っていうのは
もうそれでもって人間というのは明るくなるんですよ
だから この世の教えが世の中にはないんです
こういう風に世の中 命を見ることは誰もやってないんです
キリスト教でもイスラム教でもどちらでもやってないんです
ヒンドゥー教でも 暗いんですよ
あまりにも暗いんです
全てもう事実に逆らったこと
事実でないことを言っているんだから
ですから もう貧困になっちゃうと
人間っていうのはもう精神的にも衰えちゃう
貧困な状態だから ほんのちょっとのもう小さな果物一個についても喧嘩する
怪我させるかもしれません
殺し合いもやるかもしれません
パン 1枚にでも それぐらい惨めになる
では豊かになったらどうなるかというと
また同じことになる 互いに知らないことになる
[背景音楽]私も蜂の巣みたいにできてる建物にいるんですけど
隣は誰がいるかと まるっきり知らないし
知りたくもない そういうあまりにも狭い人生になるんです
これ本来の生き方 人間っていうのはすごく狭く生きていられないんですよ
人間というのは群れで生きる動物なんですけど
豊かさはそういうことを招くんですね
貧困もまた同じこと 食べるものないんだから
もう一人が来るとものすごい嫌なんですね
自分には足らないのに
これ分けられませんよと
豊かになるとまた同じことですよ
一人が来ると困りますよと
だから人間はもう白か黒かという極端でしか物事を考える能力はないんです
とにかく人間考えることにはろくなことはないとブッダが言うんです
物事を考えることはできるのは
真理を発見した人に限るんだよと
事実知ってる人に限るんだよと
それでブッダが言うことに何か偽りあるのかと
あなた方は調べてみなさいよと
いうオープンチャレンジで説法していて
ずっとオープンチャレンジであるんですけど
誰も興味がないだけでね
もう研究しようとはしない
今の世界のこのバカどもたちがね
これちょっと調べてみると
いくらでもどんな国際問題にも
どんな民族争いにもきちんと答えがあるのに
それまた実行不可能なものでも
観念的なものでも何でもないんです
すごい簡単で解決できるのに
これがむちゃくちゃむちゃくちゃと
だから殺し合いということが正しい世界になってくる
そういうわけだから やっぱり人間っていうのはね
事実見た方が 事実に背くことは良くない
で この偈ではもう言っているのは
人間っていうのはもうバカどもで
もう何も準備しないでグーグーと寝ているんだけど
もう水で流れてしまいますよと
森いっぱい花が咲いたところで
むちゃくちゃになって花は住んでるんですけど
その時死が来て持っていくんだよと
何か出来事起きたでしょうかね
ストーリーがありますから読んでみてくださいと
[読経]